[Applause]
at an event celebrating operation warp
speed
trump credited his administration with
producing vaccines more rapidly than has
ever been done before
today we're on the verge of another
american medical
miracle and that's what people are
saying people that aren't necessarily
big fans of donald trump are saying
whether you like him or not
this is one of the greatest miracles in
the history of modern day
medicine he said that the food and drug
administration
would likely authorize the biontech
pfizer vaccine within days
and the moderna vaccine soon after
officials from biden's transition team
who will oversee the bulk of the
vaccination rollout
were not invited instead biden held his
own parallel event
he introduced his new pandemic response
team and laid out his top priorities for
the start of his tenure
masking vaccinations opening schools
these are the three key goals for my
first 100 days
like trump biden made promises about
getting americans vaccinated quickly
this team will help get at the latest at
the last
100 million covert 19 vaccine at least
100 million coveted vaccine shots into
the arms of the american people
in the first hundred days a hundred
million shots
in the first hundred days but biden
warned that without funding from
congress
vaccination efforts could quickly stall
developing a vaccine is only one
herculean task
distributing it is another herculean
task
he also said that getting kids back to
school was a major priority
and that he'd mandate a mask requirement
in federal buildings and on public
transportation
on day one of taking office my first
hundred days
won't end the covet 19 virus i can't
promise that
but i'm absolutely convinced that in 100
days we can change the course of the
disease
and change life in america for the
better
both sides of the aisle appear to be
throwing their weight
behind what could soon become the
biggest vaccination effort
in the nation's history
let's take a look now some other
developments in the pandemic
israel received its first shipment of
coronavirus vaccines on wednesday the
country is expected to receive enough
vaccine for about a quarter of the
population by the end of the year
and israel plans to start administering
the vaccines on december 20th
china has tested more than a quarter of
a million people
for covet 19 after a handful of new
cases were detected in the southern city
of chengdu
and south korea reported 686
new coronavirus cases on wednesday as it
battles a third wave of infection that
is threatening to overwhelm the health
system
the daily tally is the second highest
since the start of the pandemic
coronavirus numbers are climbing in
turkey which now ranks
fourth globally in the highest number of
daily cases
doctors there are sounding the alarm
after months of pressure by health
experts and opposition politicians the
government has reintroduced stricter
rules to contain the pandemic
dw's yulia hahn has more
iris is celebrating her birthday she
turns eight today
her two biggest wishes a harry potter
cake
and meeting her best friends
[Music]
[Applause]
the letter is more difficult to organize
since stricter coronavirus measures have
come into force in turkey
young people under the age of 20 are
only allowed to leave their homes
for three hours a day
i used to be able to go outside whenever
i wanted
that was much better i also missed
school
now everything is done while i zoom and
it's so annoying
is trying to organize life as best as
she can between work
and curfew she's often surprised how
quickly the children have adapted
to the difficult situation
the kids wear their masks without
complaining even when they're playing
they got used to it only when we look at
old photos
do we notice that the masks weren't
always there
[Music]
curfews for children are not the only
new anti-coronavirus rule in
turkey those older than 65 can also
only go outside at certain times public
transportation is forbidden
for young and old people and on weekends
everyone with few exceptions has to stay
at home
it looks pretty bleak these days in
istanbul's usually
very busy neighborhoods restaurants bars
many shops
closed until recently the turkish
government
only published the number of covet 19
patients
showing clear symptoms and that's why
many people here thought
turkey was surviving the crisis
relatively well
but now the authorities have started to
release data on the number of
all new infections every day and many
are realizing
turkey is one of the worst affected
countries in the world
the government now reports about thirty
thousand
new infections per day
many of us are angry about how the
government is managing the crisis
but there is nothing we can do
the government is concerned with its
reputation they want to look good
that is why there is no transparency
they should have informed people much
better right from the beginning
then everyone would have known what to
expect and how to act
19 patients he's a family doctor and
belongs to the turkish medical
association
he says the authorities are still hiding
the true extent of the crisis
we still have a lot more cases than the
government says
according to our estimates we have about
fifty thousand
to sixty thousand new infections per day
our doctors and hospitals are at the
absolute limit
we have to urgently take radical
countermeasures
iris thinks the current restrictions are
already plenty tough
her party is over the kids have to go
back inside
next year she hopes for a birthday
without
the coronavirus
[Applause]
that report there from our correspondent
yulia han in istanbul and she's standing
by for us with more on this story
hi yulia good to see you can you explain
to us why
turkey has different restrictions for
the young and also for the old
julia can you hear us
yep
all right it looks like we're having
some trouble with uh julia hans line
there
julia can you hear us i'll try one more
time here
i can hear you now okay julia we were
just taking a look at your report and i
wanted to know if you
could explain to us why there are
different restrictions in turkey for the
young
and for the old
well the turkish government first
introduced stay-at-home orders for those
aged 65
and older and those aged 20 or younger
in april when the pandemic started
basically arguing that the elderly are a
risk group
that needs protection while asymptomatic
young people
might fuel the spread of the virus now
both age groups combined make up about
40 of the turkish population and since
most of them are not part of the
workforce keeping them at home and
that's certainly part of the reasoning
here
is less harmful to the economy than
let's say similar measures targeted at
the working
population in spring though the curfews
were much
tougher the young and the elderly were
completely banned from leaving their
homes for about two months
and the authorities argued that this
helped bring the numbers down so what
we're seeing now
is somehow a softer version of the
curfews we saw earlier this year
while the overall coronavirus situation
here in turkey is much worse
than it was in spring you mentioned in
your report you leave
the discrepancies between how turkey has
been reporting new covet 19
infections so how clear is the picture
there of the situation right now
well my impression is that the pandemic
here in turkey
risks spiraling out of control many
people we speak to
either know someone who tested positive
for covet 19 or
someone who even died from the virus now
we have the official figures published
by the turkish health ministry
and according to this we had more than
33
000 new infections in the last 24 hours
that's the highest number reported since
the beginning of the pandemic it's also
the highest number in
europe right now the official death rate
has also more than
doubled in less than three weeks now
these figures are already very alarming
if you now listen to what the turkish
medical association says and it
represents most of the countries doctors
the actual figures
are even higher and now add to this
their warning some say it's actually a
cry for help that
hospitals are full that icu's are full
especially here
in istanbul all of this is painting a
very grim picture
given that alarming situation yulia do
you think that the current measures that
are in place
are enough to curb the spread
well the turkish medical association the
doctor we spoke to for the report
clearly say no they say in a city like
istanbul with
16 million people you would actually
need to shut everything down for at
least 14 days to
relax the situation in the hospitals at
least a little
i don't think we're going to see
anything like this because the
government already said that they want
to
avoid any additional economic
pain but the government government now
is being criticized a lot for their lack
of transparency
for giving uh the economy a priority
in this health crisis and for acting
too little too late dw julia han in
istanbul forest thank you very much